[Music]
last night's NCAA Men's Basketball
Championship featured some special
guests with the right stuff they are the
four astronauts who were just named to
fly on the first mission around the moon
in more than half a century the crew of
Artemis 2 includes the first woman the
first black astronaut assigned to a
lunar Mission our Mark Strassman spoke
to the astronauts and joins us now from
Houston Mark good morning
hey Nate good morning to you starting
this June this mock-up capsule behind me
is going to be part of this new Cruise
training for the next 18 months and when
they fly they're going to join a very
select group only two dozen people have
ever seen such a close-up view of the
Moon
ladies and gentlemen your Artemis 2 crew
crew NASA has its own final four this
astronaut crew leading a new lunar
Mission their selection realizing a
lifelong dream puts them over the moon
we've spent our entire lives looking up
at the moon and now we're gonna go out
there and look back at Earth
from that same distance
that is crazy on this diverse Artemis 2
crew three Americans all space veterans
and a Canadian Reed Weissman a U.S Navy
Captain and the mission Commander Victor
Glover the first black astronaut to make
a long duration space flight Christina
cook a member of the first three
all-female spacewalks and Canadian
Jeremy Hansen the only space rookie
aboard first trip to space and you're
going to the Moon you won the astronaut
Powerball
wait wait
big this moment is and I personally feel
it's so much bigger than me or my name
being attached to it after launch the
Orion capsule will reach the moon in
four days for a lunar flyby This Crew
could push deeper into space than any
humans ever before finishing their
10-day Mission a moon landing Mission
would follow NASA envisions the moon as
a Proving Ground for its eventual goal
Mars
and liftoff of Artemis one Artemis 2
will be only the second Flight of the
mammoth SLS rocket and the first for the
Orion capsule using its entire life
support system Indian preparation is
about the lack of a track record is
there trepidation
absolutely it's the first crude flight
of a vehicle but we're that's like what
we live for and we are taught as
astronauts to take any kind of that
trepidation that fear you may call it
and turn it into focus and our focus is
100 on being successful in this vehicle
for NASA the stakes are high Artemis 2
just has to go well for the space agency
to have any chance of Landing Artemis 3
on the moon later this decade
Natalie Mark Strassman thanks so much